thank you
[Music]
so we had recently talked about you know
Kanye anti-Semitism about ba and then
one of the subcategories of that was
Kyrie Irving everybody remember Kyrie
Kyrie Irving not at all repost some sort
of Twitter [ __ ] just catch everybody up
on uh this film I think it was called
like Hebrews to Negroes or something
like that right is that what it was
called I think it was called that uh and
that sounds like a joke no I think it
was literally called Hebrews to Negroes
and then it was like Black America wake
up or something like that um that was
the actual name of it and then uh there
are some uh anti-semitic remarks in it
so he also gets into this whole
cancellation thing blah blah so through
that people like LeBron James and a
bunch of other like you know because it
was just like Hot Topics in the news
even though they didn't have anything to
do with it so to speak but they were you
know they're influential and in kind of
like very no names in the basketball
scene they would be in post-game
interviews and stuff and people would
always bring it up because that's the
drama everybody wants to talk about the
gossip everyone wants to talk about the
drama they want their takeout LeBron
might have like 40 games 40 points in
that night blah blah has nothing to do
with anything but they'll be like hey
what do you think about Kyrie Irving and
his anti-semitic blah blah right and
that would just be a thing
nothing nothing really newsworthy about
that that's just normal [ __ ] that
happens right and then recently if
anybody is familiar with the with the
Dallas Cowboys Dallas Cowboys Dallas
Cowboys Jerry Jones a photo had recently
popped up that looks like this
the red arrow is pointing to said Jerry
Jones jarrah if you can see that you
wanna there's that I want to see it
there so he's in the Crowd Oh that's old
school oh no he's on the wrong side if
you focus on what's actually happening
in the photo this is that a school and
there's is that the inner uh integration
times where they were forcing it says
it's in 1957. okay so you can basically
assume what's going on you could see wow
uh if you look close up you can look at
the facial expressions and stuff like
that and basically what people smoking
looks so cool I know especially back
then what's the coolest shirt it is it
is the coolest everyone dressed so nice
and it's really cool hairstyles
their outfits are still like red shoes
We're All supporting the wrong side
right now okay all right point is uh
they're talking about this photo showing
the Dallas Cowboys owner as a teenager
standing with a group of white
classmates who were trying to prevent
six black students from entering an
Arkansas School
yikes this photo pops out you know
obviously it's from 1957 so it's like
something happened a long time ago
people make mistakes or whatever but
this popped up and it you know flashed
in the news
LeBron James has his terrific game just
the other night uh post the game
interview happens
regular post game interview nothing
spectacular and then it finishes but at
the very end he's like whoa I mean he
like wants to ask the reporters a
question and he's like hey I just want
to ask you guys a question before you
guys leave I was thinking when I was on
my way over here I was wondering why I
haven't gotten a question from you guys
about the Jerry Jones Photo
when the Kyrie Irving thing was going on
you guys were quick to ask us questions
about that when I watched Kyrie talk and
he says I know who I am but I want to
keep the same energy and we're talking
about my people and things that we've
been through blah blah AKA Black America
and what you know they've gone through
in America and I feel like as a black
man as a black athlete as someone with
power and a platform well we do
something wrong or something that people
don't agree with it's on every single
tabloid every single news coverage it's
on the bottom ticker it's asked about
every single day oh yeah right that's
true but he's wondering why he's not
getting asked about this how come
nobody's bringing this up house he cuts
the checks he's been brushed under the
rug so to speak and that became his
moment to use his post-game interview
Hot Topic times like by the way that up
watch Bill Gates only get positive press
because he [ __ ] bought the Press yeah
and doesn't out doesn't uh [ __ ] Bezos
own Washington Post now yeah he does
pretty favorable coverage there I heard
is that what they told him
we're gonna take care of you so after
that what did the journalists go you
know God damn right that's true well
people were actually the funny thing is
if you watch the interview you know
people are already kind of starting to
count to questions but LeBron's like let
me finish let me finish and then he ends
up saying he's like I don't even really
care for an answer to you guys and he
just wanted to say that he's like I just
want to point that out you know what I
mean because like for example Jones
meanwhile has been under siege for the
last few days after the Washington Post
specifically published the controversial
uh photos from last week the 80 year old
though has avoided any punishment from
the NFL while denying any participation
in borrowing the black students from the
school he said he was simply a curious
Observer
which could be true too because we don't
know he's just there in the picture we
don't know what his intentions are yeah
that's so tough we don't know if he was
actually a part of the group that was
like no blacks in our school or he's all
like what the hell's going on there's
cameras and [ __ ] and he's like peeking
over we absolutely don't know he he
actually added during a different
interview he said I think the key thing
is for me is that it's a misread if you
think that I don't recognize how
Monumental those days were
um so like obviously that he really
could have been a bystander and that's
just how the times were yeah but I think
the point I don't think LeBron was even
saying yeah exactly and the ball's not
be like this guy's a racist guilty he's
just more like hey we you know we get
highlighted into everything if we
remotely do something that's slightly
out of tone and same thing with Kyrie I
think his defense was that like you know
Kyrie's not being like I hate Jews he
just retweeted something that has
potentially conflicting views or
anti-semitic views but this is like he's
not getting questioned about it you know
know what I mean and this is something
that specifically has to do with black
America which is like definitively like
his history and culture so that's why
he's bringing it up and yeah that's why
I don't like mainstream media at all but
then sometimes I wonder if it's like
they're being puppeted or for them
they're like oh that story's not gonna
go viral but this story that's gonna go
viral it's you know it's an athlete
versus like a sports team owner like
young people probably care more about
the athlete well also let's be as real
as we can right like like journalists
get paid like a lot of times by the
article that they write and like you
know if you [ __ ] with sponsorships or
you [ __ ] with like big players who can
[ __ ] with your sponsorships you don't
want to even rock that boat that's why
no one wants to touch the Epstein stuff
exactly and they don't that makes sense
and especially for Kyrie too it's like
I'm not saying it's fair for people to
come down to him but like any chance
they get they always go after Kyrie they
have ever since he came out against the
covered stuff yeah like any time they
anytime they can make them look as kooky
as possible no he was a vaccine I think
he was too I think he was a flat earther
too was he
he must have been a flat earther I think
he was I didn't know that so and anytime
they can yeah but regardless of that uh
just that very last thing that you had
said yeah or that topic in general the
idea of things either being viral like
worth the news or like something that's
not uh you know aggravating the sponsors
or whatever right I think that's an
interesting thing because
um let's talk virality right
um do you guys remember in Tick Tock uh
maybe like a year ago or something like
that there was
um you know black people were basically
boycotting some element of tick tock
because a black creators were talking
about how they do all these like dance
Trends or challenges and they they're
the ones that are creating these
challenges to like uh you know um
different so I forget
but it's the uh the white influencers
who are doing those dance strands that
are going super viral so it's like is it
the algorithm is it the this is that how
come it's only the white influencers
that are going super viral with with
these challenges but the people who
created them the black creators for some
reason they're not getting the same
attention love XYZ or whatever and again
yeah sure why can't why won't um China
Post Billboards of a movie with a black
guy on it like who owns Tick Tock like
like yeah I mean yeah pretty [ __ ]
conducive right there right like that's
that's part of their thing for some
reason like you know John boyega was
edited out of the Star Wars force
awakens poster it was China that's crazy
like [ __ ] he's a he's like the main
star he like opens the [ __ ] movies
and all the whole goddamn movie
but like yeah he was edited out of the
post is that why he's not in the rest of
the [ __ ] movies dude he's like barely
you know we should talk about that too I
have yeah he was the most interesting
character
Stormtrooper then they just make him a
side cheerleader yelling Ray the whole
time [ __ ] sucks yeah I was like
what's really really weird he was Rob
that is weird because they love the NBA
in China and so
it does make sense but it's also weird
how they cherry pick what they want to
showcase but I guess more so like you
know that just kind of like begs the
question a little bit of like who's in
charge slash like what makes these
decisions that allow certain things to
happen and again I'm not many I have no
idea many people are critical of
LeBron's lack of criticism in China so
then this gets like really [ __ ] weird
like you know what I mean like it just
comes in it just seems like it always
comes down to money it's like if if
Kyrie saying something [ __ ] with
someone else's money then they're gonna
have to figure out how to how to put a
stop to it or address it if that picture
coming out of Jerry Jones ends up
[ __ ] with someone's money then
they're gonna address it but if they
don't talk about it it won't [ __ ] with
anyone's money so they'll just be like
okay this is not causing any Discord
people think that the world operates way
too much on morality when it doesn't
know special interest how dare they
think that yeah I know but but like
common folks that's because common folks
do operate on morality yeah they think
they think that we operate on I ideally
operate on morality but but in most
cases if you think about the middle
class worldwide right and and the poor
the working class right like their value
system respect system a lot of it
doesn't have anything to do with money
because they don't have money so what
they value could be sports teams or
religion or things that they value
themselves in because that becomes their
identity and they don't own property
they don't own things that are okay give
me the shirt off their back I mean dude
you talk you talk about people who are
like touring through some of these like
countries where low-income people guess
what they're the first people to embrace
you first people to feed you yeah first
people to close and because they operate
on ethics and morals like that right
they believe that people on top are
doing the same things which they have no
[ __ ] clue how they're being puppet is
it's Elysium because it's like that's
why you can divide and conquer if you
have a sports team right and let's say
like you guys are the Catholics or you
guys are the Christians and you can make
them battle or whatever the [ __ ] it's
like these different groups you can
easily divide and conquer and then it's
like everything else is motivated by
streams of income depending on hey this
the every single organization needs
income to survive so if you cut that
stream out you're actually [ __ ] with
these people Hollywood's terrified of
the like the Chinese market as far as
like oh yeah dude they [ __ ] spread
their ass cheeks whichever they want
right like over here it's like hey guess
what we're so proud of this movie we
have gay characters and they're gonna
kiss each other and all this stuff and
then internet's cut yeah and they're
like so proud over here but yep not over
there it's like pre-cut they're not
cutting it when they're told to they're
just like oh here's the movie they're
being good boys China's down with John
Cena and The Rock dude they're good
that's Hollywood right there they just
make movies for those guys but yeah I
also think it's if you can't really
criticize the Press about like how come
you're not covering this it's like
they're selling the news that's it it's
not entertainment it's not that part of
a story that Jerry Jones was found in a
[ __ ] photo way back but Kyrie just
posted this thing and the timing with
Kanye is awesome for a headline to be
like hey you just remembered what Kanye
did look what he did it like ties in
perfectly it's selling news
I do love him asking this question
though the economics is both needed I
love it yeah
[Music]
[Music]
foreign